[Música]
hora de hablar de medio ambiente en
france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y hoy
hablaremos de los desastres climáticos y
es que cada 13 de octubre se celebra el
día internacional para la reducción de
riesgos de desastres una fecha clave
porque los eventos meteorológicos
extremos son cada vez más frecuentes el
ipc se advirtió que los desastres se
intensificarán y que en los últimos 50
años se quintuplicaron aunque en todo el
mundo se sienten las consecuencias los
países en desarrollo son los que más
muertos ponen con el 91 por ciento de
los decesos por desastres desde 1970 en
cambio los países más ricos son los que
mayores pérdidas económicas han tenido
asia es la región donde más desastres ha
habido con un 31% de los eventos le
sigue en américa del norte centroamérica
y el caribe luego áfrica europa el
sudeste asiático y por último sur
américa además cada región del mundo
padece más con un tipo de eventos por
ejemplo en áfrica azotan las sequías y
en europa las olas de calor mientras que
las tormentas y las inundaciones son las
más devastadoras en el resto del mundo
américa se perfila como una de las áreas
que más sufrirán con la crisis climática
el 2020 fue el año con más tormentas en
la historia al tener 30 eventos y
huracanes como yo está dieta mientras
que el sur del continente sufrió con la
peor sequía que ha habido en la amazonía
y en el humedal el pantanal en los
últimos 60 años conversamos con nahuel
arenas jefe adjunto para las américas de
la oficina de la onu para la reducción
del riesgo de desastres quien nos habló
de los impactos en la región en la
región de las américas y el caribe
estamos viendo todos los días como los
eventos hidrometeorológicos están en
aumento más mayor frecuencia mayor
intensidad y ya antes de la pandemia
esta región suponía y sufría el 53 por
ciento de las pérdidas económicas
globales a partir de los eventos
extremos climáticos y esto solo va a
seguir profundizándose por lo tanto creo
que como digo en este momento histórico
es hora de hacer un balance de los
esfuerzos y recomendar estrategias de
alianzas para lograr economías y
sociedades más resilientes que pongan el
tema de los riesgos en el centro de la
agenda climática y de la agenda del
desarrollo sostenible una de las grandes
preguntas que se hace la ciencia es que
tanto los desastres están siendo
causados por el cambio climático y
cuáles son las responsabilidades del ser
humano en esto abuela arenas nos habló
al respecto el último informe del ipcc
es contundente con respecto al rol de
los seres humanos en el cambio climático
y a nivel global sólo estamos destinando
el 0,5 por ciento repito a 0 5 por
ciento de la cooperación internacional
para prevención por lo tanto tampoco
estamos haciendo lo suficiente al
respecto entonces
creo que es momento de que tengamos un
enfoque realmente multisectorial frente
a los riesgos la pandemia nos ha
mostrado y el cambio climático también
nos muestran como el riesgo en los
sistemas
económicos ambientales de salud etcétera
tienen efectos en todos los sistemas los
efectos se sienten especialmente en los
grupos más vulnerables por ejemplo las
mujeres y los menores de edad son los
que suelen padecer más en el ciclón
narguis de 2008 en mianmar murieron el
doble de mujeres que de hombres y la
mayoría de las personas que quedaron
atrapadas por el huracán katrina en
estados unidos eran mujeres todo por el
papel subordinado que usualmente tiene
la mujer en el lugar
la abuela arena se explica esto y
también resalta el liderazgo femenino en
las reconstrucciones
muchas veces por ejemplo en el caso de
un desastre de las mujeres son las que
se les se encargan de cuidar a los
ancianos a los adultos mayores en las
casas se las pueden a las niñas retirar
del colegio o se las pueden
les pueden dar un rol de salir a
trabajar o bueno ni hablar de mecanismos
mucho más nocivos las mujeres y las
niñas también han demostrado ser
importantes agentes de cambio e
impulsores de la reducción de riesgo de
desastres y es en este sentido que desde
generar en la región de américa y el
caribe este día 13 de octubre se lanzará
en la red de mujeres de américa latina
el caribe para la reducción de riesgo de
desastres que trata justamente de
relevar el importante rol del líder
social que ejercen las mujeres en tareas
tanto de emergencia como de
reconstrucción en caso de desastres no
sólo hay que trabajar para reducir el
riesgo de los desastres sino también
para proteger a las especies y sus
ecosistemas por eso china es el
escenario de la discusión más importante
sobre diversidad biológica la cumbre
cop15 en la ciudad de kunming es el
equivalente a la cob 26 donde se habla
de cambio climático al igual que
ocurrirá en glasgow en china el debate
de este año es fundamental para el
futuro allí discutan cuáles serán los
objetivos mundiales para proteger la
biodiversidad de aquí al 2050
we face y nos enfrentamos a nuestro
momento de la verdad y fui a tu meet the
twenty five te dije si queremos cumplir
la visión 2050 de vivir en armonía con
la naturaleza tenemos que actuar en esta
década para detener y revertir la
pérdida de biodiversidad y entrar en el
camino de recuperación a más tardar para
el 2030 este es el desafío definitivo de
nuestro tiempo por ahora hay un borrador
que discuten en la reunión virtual de
esta semana y los encuentros
presenciales de abril del otro año
también serán el escenario para esto una
de las propuestas es proteger el 30 por
ciento de las tierras y los océanos pero
está por verse que acuerda en los países
y sin duda es un tema al que le
seguiremos la pista sigan conectados con
nosotros para más información ambiental
hasta la próxima
[Música]